أول رئيس عربي يفتتح خطابه في الأمم المتحدة
بالبسملة،
لم تكن أمه تعلم بأنه الرئيس، الرئيس
الذي لم يحّمل أيا من عائلته مسؤولية المناصب،
لقبه الجزائريون بـ"الموسطاش"
أو "صاحب الشوارب" بالعربية،
أو "الزعيم"، أو "الرئيس الذي لم يتكرر"،
بعد أن عاشت البلاد خلال فترة حكمه "
عصرها الذهبي دبلوماسياً واقتصادياً".
شخصيته سحرت وألهمت الجزائريين
بكاريزما ثورية وسياسية وقومية صارمة
ولا مكان معها لخيانة الوطن أو للفساد،
استبقت أفعاله أقواله التي ظلت خالدة،
بعد أن كان أول رئيس جزائري
يرسخ مبدأ أن "الدولة لا تزول بزوال الرجال"....
(قصة هواري بومدين مع أمه)
الرئيس الجزائري الراحل هواري بومدين، الذي دفع بالجيش الجزائري
للمشاركة بقوة في الحروب العربية الإسرائيلية، وكان من أشد المدافعين
عن القضية الفلسطينية..
وفي سبعينيات القرن الماضي، وبينما كان الرئيس هواري بومدين في زيارة لوالدته،
وكانت والدته تجلس بجوار أخيه الأصغر سعيد بوخروبة،
فقال بومدين لأخيه، ما رأيك أن تذهب إلى الخدمة العسكرية،
لكن بوخروبة طلب منه أن يعفيه من هذه المهمة الوطنية،
وذهب يهمس في أذن والدته أن تخبر بومدين أن لا يدفعه للذهاب للخدمة،
ويدعه يكمل دراسته،
وقال لأمه
( بومدين يا أما رايح يوديني للعسكر وللصحراء والعقارب، ورايح نبعد عليك يا أما)،،
عندها حزنت على ولدها، وقالت
( ورحمة السعيد خويا تودي لي وليدي للعسكر وتبعدو عليا، غير نشكيك للحكومة)
(وتعني أنها أقسمت بروح شقيقها أن تشتكي الرئيس بومدين للحكومة)،
وكان أخوها السعيد قد استشهد لأجل الوطن، بينما كان رد أم بومدين طبيعي،
فهي لا تعلم أن ولدها هو الرئيس،
فتعالت ضحكات بومدين وقهقه بطريقة جنونية،
وقال كيف ستشكينني للحكومة، يا أمي، وأنتِ مع الحكومة بذاتها،،،
ثم قال لها واجب عليه أن يذهب للخدمة العسكرية كبقية الشعب،
ثم زمجر وقال لأخيه،
ستذهب مجبورا وإلا فسأبعثك إلى مكان لا ترغب بالذهاب إليه،،،
وما هي إلا أيام، وتم إرسال بوخروب لأداء الخدمة العسكرية، ولمدة
عامين كاملين وهنا تظهر الصورة الرئيس بومدين خلال زيارته لأخيه
في معسكره أثناء الخدمة الوطنية،،
نعم يا سادة لقد أرسل بومدين أخاه ليؤدي الخدمة العسكرية
وهو قادر على إعفائه، في الوقت الذي يذهب فيه أبناء وأقرباء الحكام
لقضاء أوقاتهم في الدول الغربية. إنه الرئيس الجزائري هواري بومدين،
الذي ظل في غيبوبته ٤٥يوما قبل وفاته،
ولم يجلس أحد على كرسيه احتراما له،،،
فهل يعيد الزمن نفسه ويأتي برئيس كهواري بومدين...؟
إذا أعجبك الفيديو اضغط على زر اللايك واشترك بالقناة وفعل رمز الجرس
ليصلك كل جديد على قناة شاهد لتعرف...
....